welcome back this morning the China
challenged the FBI revealing this week
that China's ambassador to the United
States was secretly recruiting
scientists to work on behalf of his
government the CCP he is attorney
general bill Barr what he told me last
weekend about the Chinese Communist
Party's ambitions say one will be the
leader in all the future technologies
that are going to dominate the economy
and so what's at stake is the economic
opportunity our children and our
grandchildren whether we can continue to
be the technological leader of the world
Senator Tom cotton is a Republican from
Arkansas he first sounded the alarm
about China right here on this program
back in February and he joins me once
again
senator it is good to see this morning
thanks very much for joining us I want
to talk about the legislation that you
have introduced but let's start with
some of this new imagery that we have
which basically shows the Chinese
Communist Party militarizing right at
the India border China you have said and
others have said is using this kovat
pandemic as an opportunity to gain more
ground can you tell me about it
Mariya the Chinese Communist Party is
certainly using the pandemic to try to
assert claims and take very aggressive
action against almost all of its
neighbors just go around the horn you
started in India where high up in the
Himalayas China has essentially invaded
India and a liar's and they've killed 20
Indian soldiers and then in Hong Kong
they passed legislation that violates
their international commitments their
commitments to the people of Hong Kong
that is essentially going to turn Hong
Kong into the same kind of police state
mainland China yes and in the South
China Sea they've taken aggressive
action against our partners countries
like the Philippines Malaysia Vietnam
they've repeatedly invaded the airspace
in recent weeks of Taiwan and just this
past week they've taken aggressive
action against Japan in the East China
Sea China is becoming more aggressive
than ever that's why it's so important
that we support all of our allies and
partners that we make it clear to China
we will not tolerate this kind of action
that we want competition to remain
peaceable but the way that happens is to
make it clear that we stand with those
partners and allies senator the Pentagon
this week revealed that
more than 20 companies Communist Chinese
military companies operating inside the
United States they're doing joint
ventures that buying company is they're
getting money from our capital markets
how is this possible that we have so
much you know companies in our own
capital markets that are actually
undermining national security well
unfortunately it reflects a
long-standing bureaucratic and
establishment indifference if the threat
to China poses the Department of Defense
to its credit finally produce a list of
Chinese companies that are controlled by
or closely affiliated with the People's
Liberation Army that's been a
requirement in the law since 1999 it was
only when I and a few other legislators
brought it to the Department of
Defense's attention that they actually
researched the question and published
that list this is an example of what
China calls civil military fusion where
they use cutting-edge civilian companies
as fronts to increase their military
technology even in competitive countries
like the United States that needs to
stop today you have introduced
legislation the American Foundry's Act
of 2020 supporting the production and
development of micro electronics in
America this was 14 billion dollars that
you would like to have available to do
that walk us through this legislation
senator so maria semiconductors are
essential foundational even to a modern
economy not just advanced stealth
fighter jets but all of the basic
electronics in our lives unfortunately
we don't make that many in the United
States the Trump administration has been
very effective at stopping American
technology going to semiconductors going
into China but what we really need to do
is increase the productive capacity of
our economy which are providing good
high-paying jobs as well in the
semiconductor conductor sector that's
why I and other senators are working on
legislation we hope to pass maybe as
earlier this week to provide direct
support to companies that want to bring
semiconductor manufacturing back to the
United States do you want the u.s. to
take a stake in Ericsson or Nokia as a
way to tell the world look there are
Western telecom companies to be
use away from Huawei well that's one
possibility Maria the problem is that
Huawei is not a private company as we
imagine it's our arm of the Chinese
Communist Party
so when wall weight goes into a country
that country knows that they have the
full backing of the Chinese government
they also grow into a threat so for
instance they might tell Germany that if
you don't use wall way technology then
you can't sell Mercedes or BMW s in
China
what Nokia and Ericsson and Samsung and
South Korea need is the support of
United States and other Western
countries so they compete on equal terms
whether that's a direct stake or export
financing or another alternative would
be to provide an open radio access
network that would provide small and
medium-sized companies the opportunity
to compete for this business as well so
it's not dominated by just a handful of
tech companies around the world but
what's really essential is to have Bible
competitive alternatives to what way all
right let me let me switch gears I want
to ask you about the 2020 election I've
got this Cowan & Company report here and
Cowan and company tells its clients that
if Biden were to win Elizabeth Warren
will be the key voice on economic policy
I want to get your take on that and also
the house just approving DC statehood
senator they want to make Washington DC
a state answer those two issues because
our audience is very interested in
hearing what Biden is doing I heard it's
already agreed upon she's either gonna
be Treasury Secretary but even if she's
not she's going to be the most important
economic voice yeah well Joe Biden has
really had much of an agenda Joe Biden
is hiding out in his basement he has
been a weather vane for the Democratic
Party fads and fashions for the last 50
years that's why it was always soft on
communism the Soviet Union that's why I
always voted to outsource our jobs to
China while he's still to this day so
that China is not one of our competitors
but that means when he gets in office he
is simply going to be a vessel for the
radical left of the Democratic Party
whether it's Elizabeth Warren's economic
policies or the mobs that we see in the
streets tearing down statues in an
instance of mob violence or passing a DC
statehood bill look our founding fathers
won in Washington DC to be a federal
city and that's what it is it's a city
it's not a state and it's a federal city
because
the federal government needs to have
control of the seat of government our
founding fathers were experienced with
the kind of mutinies that you could face
in Philadelphia were Congress at at the
time or you know it just mob violence in
the street a few weeks ago
that's why Washington DC needs to remain
a federal city in the end what the
Democrats want is not voting rights for
the residents of Washington if they did
that they could just return it to
Maryland as we did with the Virginia
side of Washington in the 1840s they
want two Democratic senators in
perpetuity because the American people
have denied them control of the
government for these last ten years this
is all just an example of what Joe Biden
will do this is about getting to six
because you could give me you could give
them you could give the residential
parts of Washington back to Maryland it
would get its own house seat because
it's about the size of a House District
and it would be represented by Maryland
senators what it wouldn't get is two new
Democratic senators that's what this is
all about okay and real quick on
Elizabeth Warren I know she has proposed
a wealth tax she wants to raise taxes
and she also wants to she wants to break
up companies want to break up technology
companies and tries to break up banks is
there anything else we should understand
if she is the key economic voice well I
think that Ronald Reagan's old line
about democratic economic policy would
apply to senator war and other Democrats
are going to be influencing Joe Biden if
it moves tax it if it keeps moving
regulated if it dies subsidize it that's
their economic policy all right senator
it's good to have you this morning thank
you so much for joining us Senator Tom
cotton we'll see you soon sir thank you